日本の音声学エピソード33の公開リリース
へようこそ。これ
は、過去に別の
常連客が前に出てき
て、このビデオは特に本当に面白いと思ったので、
他の常連客が過去にしたように私があなたに支払ったなら、あなたはこれを一般
に公開することをいとわないだろう
と私
は確かにそうしようと言ったので、ここで私たち
のレッスンが
利用可能になりました youtubeみんなが見
て、過去のようにええと、私はこのレッスンに
ある種の補足メモ
をするつもりですえ
えと、誰かがこれを疑問に思っているなら、これは
私がついに
日本の私の場所に到着したドーガングッズです
誰か
がこれに興味を持っているなら、私は以下のリンクを残しますが、それは
おそらく今のところイントロとしては良いと思います
私は
このレッスンをリリース
できることを本当に嬉しく思います 特に初心者
にとっては本当に大きな違いが
ありますので、
皆さんがビデオを楽しんでくれることを願っています。さあ、
今すぐ
始めましょう。みなさん、こんにちは。発音サブシリーズの最初のエピソードである、
ドーゲンによる日本語音声学の第33話へようこそ。
私は発音、特に発音
について話し始めることに本当に興奮
しています。それは、日本語の音声学に存在する単一の独立した規則のすべてが、
私の話す日本語にはるかに大きな影響を与え
たためです。 多くの皆さん
もこれは非常に高度な
概念ではないので、
より高度な学習者の多くは、今日
私たちが学んでいることをすでにかなり知っていると
思いますが、それでも私たちがそれをカバーする方法が証明されることを願っています
私が大学で日本語を勉強し始めたとき
、私の
最終目標はいつか
natと話すことでした。 何千もの漢字を知るのではなく、イブのようなアクセント
私は日本人のように聞こえたかったので
、音声学が何であるかを知る前から、最初から
発音にかなり関心があり
ました。 時々、できるだけ多くのネイティブスピーカーとたむろしようとしました。
この
ため、発音に関して
は非常に誇りを持っていました。コミカルな量のプライドは、この
プライドによって
、他の日本人学習者の発音を非常に意識するようになりました。
誰か
が私よりも文法を知っていても気にしませんでしたが、彼ら
が私よりも発音が良かった場合、私は
基本的に否定の状態になりましたが、
そのように話すことができ
ます 半分
日本人の半分アメリカ人の学生
が私が真似できない一見単純なフレーズを言うのを聞いたとき
、それは私を夢中にさせました私は
彼がそのフレーズを正しいと言っていることを知っていました tlyと私
はなぜフレーズを正しく言うことができなかったのか分かりませんでしたなぜ私が
フレーズに巻き込まれ続けたのか
は非公式に
行きたい
と書かれていますこのように書かれ
ています今すぐこれを言うことを心配しないでください
詳細に入る ほんの数分で
、この生徒のように何
度もこのフレーズを言おうとしても
できなかったのです。それは、
日本語を学び始めたときに教えられ
た規則によって無意識のうちに演奏した日本語の発音規則によるものです。
日本語の発音を学ぶときに間違っていた
ほとんどの人
は次のフレーズの変形に出くわします
日本語の発音は
5つの母音と14の
子孫
しかないので簡単です。
eieなど日本語eは常にeと同じように
発音されます。
これは、日本語の
イントネーションがフラット
であるのと同じように、非常に単純化されています。
彼らが教えていることは
、かつて話された日本人の自然さを大きく制限するので、信じてください。
すべての音が常に同じように発音される
場合、すぐに発音されたいというフレーズは
、私の18歳の自分が問題なく模倣できたであろうイクガです。
しかし、それは真実ではありません。そのため、
すぐに言いたいというフレーズはイカではありませ
んが、違いに注意してください。
ここで正確に起こっている
ことは、この現象を話し言葉で詳細に調べてみましょう。
母音と子音
母音は非常に簡単に言えば、
声道の振動によって開いた声道で引用される
このフレーズの2番目の部分は、母音
を生成するときに重要です。
母音をかみ合わせるとき
は、5つの日本の母音を言って、
間違いなくこれを確認しながら、指を喉に当ててみてください。
これらの音のいずれかを作成すると、声道
が独立した母音を
振動させることに注意してください。
一方、子音を生成するときの
あなたの声の子音は、あなたの呼吸が少なくとも
部分的に妨げられている
音です。子音は、有声または無声のいずれか
です。たとえば、無声の子音は、
指を喉に当てながら音を出してみて
ください。
振動はありません。 繰り返しますが、これは
tが無声子音であるためです
。dはこの子音で
私たちの声のコードが使用されているので、d
は有声子音です。これは実際には
tとdの唯一の違いです。
私たちの唇は顎など
です私たちは単に声のコードを使って広告を作成し
ます
今あなたは間違いなくこれに気づいてい
ますが、日本語ではt
とdの音は実際に
は同じ文字で表されます唯一の違い
はこれが文字通り声を意味するdakdenをマークする
ことです
マークは、母音で有声のトップとエンドの両方が
実際に有声で始まります。
そのため、ドキュメントがあり、ボイス
マークのトップは無声で始まります。
声のマークがないので、
この違いに注意
してください。ダクテンまたは
声のマークが付いた他のいくつかの音があります。たとえば、gの音は
単に
dokdenを使用したkの音です。これは
、kとgの音の違いが唯一の理由です。
gの
音を言うとき、私たちは声のコードを使用します
kgは有声のkです同様に
zは有声ですsのbは有声の
pなどです
日本人の言語学者
は当時これに気づき
、実用的な方法でそれを反映するように日本語のアルファベットを作成しました。
この知識は興味深いですが
、日本語で独立した音
を言う方法はまだ変わってい
ません。 声を出し始めますが、これは
私たちが言う方法を変えませ
ん。言語学で物事が面白くなる
ところは、予測可能な
発声と発声の現象があり、これは
本質的に次のことを意味します。
周囲の音
が有声であるかどうかに基づいて、音は予想どおりに変化
します。たとえば、英語の単語カップでは
、前の
子音pは無声である
ため、sは通常の無声sとして発音されます。
一方、赤ちゃんのクマのようにカブス
という言葉を見ると、声の勢い
に気づきます。ここ
で、単語の最後のsは、
カブスではなくカブスではなく、カブスではなく、azのように発音され
ます。
前の
音bは濁音であるため、sは濁りを受け取ります。したがって、カブスはカブスと言います。カブスと言う
のは実際には困難で不自然
です。
英語のsが
sとzの両方の音を出す方法と同じように、日本の
eは部分的または完全に濁り
、日本の
ku
は周囲の音に応じてkuとkの両方の音を出すことが
できます。 これを知らないで、あなたはいつも
教えられているように食べようと言い
ますそれはあなたの日本の音をより不自然にするだけでなく、
それは実際に
合理的な速度で話すことをより難しくします
日本の音は常に
グロスと同じように発音されます 過度に単純化
する
と、複数の発音を持つ日本語の音がたくさんあります。
今日
は、日本語の日本語で濁りがどのように発生するかを調べることから
始め
ます。 これよりも
、後に続く有声音がない
ので、これは日本語
で発生する濁り現象の良い例です。
日本語
で強調するためにこれを数回繰り返し
、高母音eを強調
し、無声の間に無声になると無声になります
日本語の狭母音はeで
あり、無声の子音の間にある場合、
つまりeの濁音を使用しない
場合、およびそれらがaの場合に無声になります。 無声子音の任意のペアの間に見つかった
この概念を、最初の子音に適用しましょう。この
フレーズ
の個々の音
を見ると、kuと、
それらが始まるダクテンまたは母音のマークがないことがわかります。
無声子音k
この単語のマジを表示して、これを少し簡単にしましょう。これで、
無声子音のペアの間
でこのフレーズのマジをよく見て、高母音が食べて無声になるルールはどうでした
か。  uが2つのkの2つの無声子音の間にあることがわかります。
したがって、
uは有声になります。
そのため
、母音なしで言うのではなく、母音
が
ない場合は、正しいよりもはるかに簡単に言うことができます。
このフレーズをまねるのに少し苦労し
ました。最初の数回は同じことが起こったので心配しないでください。
日本人の生徒が正しいイッカを言うのを聞いたの
ですが、
無意識のうちに声を出そうとしたので言い続けました。
e
これが間違っていることを覚えておいて
ください。リラックスして音を完全に取り除く
ことは常に同じ考え方です
が、時には完全に無声である場合もあります。
このフレーズ
をこのように綴られているかのように考え
てみてください。
ここでuを言わないようにすると、おそらくお気づきのよう
に簡単です。これは、デバイスの子音
間で高母音を発声しない方がはるかに自然であるため、フレーズ全体をはるかに速く言うことができます。
これは、実際
には、言語学における普遍的な規則です。
他の例を検討する前に、
文字通り数十から数
十の言語で問題ありません。
日本語のガイドラインを
もう一度見てみましょう。無声子音のペアの間に見つかった場合、高母音が食べて
無声になります。
これをもう少し具体的にしましょう。 次のkstchhnpのいずれかの間で
見つかった場合、eとuは離婚
します。これは、これらが
日本語のtの音であることに気付くためです。 帽子には
ダクテンまたは母音の対応物もあります。次の音がない場合、
eとuは部分的または完全に離婚することがよくありますが、必ずしもそうと
は限りません。
これが、音
がないためではなく、デスと呼ばれる理由です。
スーオーケーの後に来る有声音です
ので、これは私が最初に
いくつかの追加情報を提供したい
最初のポイントです私はeと言いましたそして次の音がない場合は有声になることができます
そしてこれはこれで
起こっていることで
あり、iiは追加されました これは事後のタイトルで
、皆さんはおそらくタイトルを見たばかりですが
、次の音がないときにeまたはuが
単語の最後で声を
出すために、母音の前に来る音な
ので、この音では uの前に来る
その音も
無声の音でなければならないので、
aeまたはuは単語の終わりに来ることができないので、単語の終わり
に来る必要が
あり、子音
も
無声の音である必要があります だからあなたが聞くたびに
いきますややりますなどのマスワードを
言っている話者
が最後にuを正しく言って
いないのは、次の音がないだけでなく
、
uhの前
の音が無声であるためです。
sとzzzを続けて
言うと、sは濁ります。zzと言うと
、声のコードが振動しているのに気付くでしょうが
、s
ではそうではありません。
eまたは
無声子音の間にある
場合、または無声子音が前に
あり、
その後に一時停止が続く場合、このレッスンにはまだ多く
の情報が
残っているので、もう一度話を
戻しましょう。簡単な例から始めて、さらにいくつかの例を見てみましょう。
ここでの人の言葉eは、2つの無声
子音
hとtの間に
あり、したがってeはdの濁りになります。これが
、最初のeという言葉で同様にひとひとではなく言う理由です。
は有声ではありませんが、2番目のeは
有声子音に続くため
有声ですb
ここではピッチアクセントを気にしないでください。
次の子音g
は有声子音であるため、eは少なくとも部分的に有声です。
一方、キクで
は、次の
子音
は無声の子音であるため、eは
濁ってい
ません。これらの2
つ
のキグキグキグのキ音を比較してください。
よくakとsの間で発生します。
これらは両方とも無声子音である
ため、uは再び濁りません
が、アクセス
は、ほとんど不可能な
日本の単語やフレーズがどのように多いかについて話
しました。 これが
すべての音が常に同じ
誤解であると信じている場合は、これらのいくつかを見てみましょう。自然なネイティブの
ような方法でこれら
を言うことがどれほど簡単であるかに気づきましょう。
この単語を音声で綴ろうとすると、私は再び疲れ果ててしまいます。これは、yoよりも
はるかに近く、
100の自然に聞こえます。さらにいくつかの
例
では
、以前のように完全に空のskusです。
ska ska
ska skada
といくつかの動詞ではなく、これとしての発音についてdekirumから始めましょう。ki
は、有声子音arの前にあるため、ここで発声されます
が、過去の形式では、このrはに
なり、このeはt
が 無声子音ではないので
、
これは少し些細なことのように思えるかもしれませんが、
同じ動詞を
2回続けて言うと、実際には
、
古い勝利者や
dektadektaとして、日本語でかなりの量が発生します。
アコースティックスのように終わる動詞の組み合わせ
は、単語のダウンステップまたはアクセントがたまたま発生した場合に、最初
に濁りを適切に理解することで、これらすべてを言うのがはるかに簡単になります。
有声母音の場合、たとえばこの母音を母音で発声
することは問題ありません。たとえば、ここの2番目はakとsの間にあるため、ダウンステップは今すぐに発生し
ます。 デボイシングのルールに関係なく、
ダウンステップの
母音は時々大丈夫です。これ
は2番目のセクションです。追加情報を提供したい
ので、ツクスに与えた例
には
、ボイシングがアクセントに影響を与えないことを示す古い高低アクセント辞書がいくつかあります。
mora
so in su
でも、kuはアクセントのあるモーラ
です。このアクセントのあるモーラは
声を受け取らないようにし、
母音の影響を受けないようにする必要があると言っている古い高低アクセントの辞書を信じるなら、
それは1つの理論的な可能性です。
なぜkuが無声化されていないのか
と
いうと、ここでもう1つもっともらしいことが起こっている
と思います。それは、複数の音がある場合です。
単語または日本語の単語の複数の種類の
音節
で、
技術的に
言えば、
2つまたは3つの音節が
連続している場合、その結果として、
単語
全体が離婚する可能性があります。
その場合、その単語はまったくピッチを持たず、それは
ネイティブの日本人話者には奇妙に聞こえるので
、この単語の私たち一人一人は、単語の構造のために
技術的に言えば離婚する可能性があり
ます
が、すべてのにじみを声に出してしまった場合 この単語
では、技術的に言え
ば、それが
回転し、最終的な発音が
なり
、母語を言わず、
また、単語は
ピッチを持たないので、そう
で
はないことがどのようにもっともらしいかについて話しました この
単語のアクセントのある音節であるために離婚しました
が、別のもっともらしい理論は
、あなたが声の手がかり
と周囲の音をした場合
、単語はcではないということです
どんなピッチでも運びます、そしてそれはオフになるでしょう、
それで
私がここで書き出す単語ソックスが
複数の正しい発音を持っている理由の1つです。
ネイティブスピーカーに
そうする
ので
、その言葉でとを離婚するので
はなく、ネイティブスピーカーはしばしば2番目の音を声に出さ
ず、部分的または完全に
そのように再びええと、それはそう
ではなく、私がしたい最後のことです
アクセントのある音節を
声に出さないネイティブスピーカーがいるということですが、声を出さなくても大丈夫だと言ったのですが、確かに声を出さ
ないスピーカーもいます
が、アクセントのある音節を再び声に出すと
、アクセントは本質
的に単語から消えます。
なぜなら、音が無声化されている
場合
、それはまったくピッチを運ばないから
です。ボーカルコードを再び
かみ合わせるのではなく、本質的にささやくだけで、
ボーカをかみ合わせる必要があります。
ある種の適切なピッチを作成するためのコード
ですが、マウラのアクセントが
まったくピッチを経験しない
場合、そのアクセントは本質的
に単語から消えて
おり、そのような場合、ネイティブ
スピーカーは次の
ような追加の発音でその単語を発音します 別の高低アクセントパターンな
ので、
この単語をゆっくりと言うとアナウンサー
の単語になります
が、この単語をすばやく言うと
、eで発声が発生しますが、eで
発声が発生すると、その
下になります。
ステップピッチが消えていくので、ピッチ
アクセントはもうありません。ある人はそこにある
かのように言うでしょう
が、他のスピーカーは
別のピッチアクセントパターンを言って単語に与えるでしょう。
基本的な理論は、アクセントが
無声化された場合、 これ
を補うために、単語の高低アクセントパターンを変更する必要があります。
これも、単語の
複数のペイチェックと
パターンを確認できる理由の1つです。  n高低アクセントと
高低アクセントの相互作用の関係については、多く
の情報が含まれて
いましたが
、この特定のセクションで重要なことは、重要
なポイントである必要があると思います。
高低アクセントと高低アクセントが
相互に作用しているためであり、
これら3つの例を暗記しようとするのではなく、技術的には高低アクセントが発生するはずのインスタンスを見つけた場合、それは頻繁ではありません。
高低アクセントはアクセントを声に出して相互作用させることができ
、時にはこれ
が単語の高低アクセントに影響を与えることがあり
ます。
または、高低アクセントが発生
した場合は、
声を聞いているときや、ネイティブの日本語を聞いている
ときは、これに注意
してください。 私が
今言ったことをすべて
理解して、ビデオの最後の考えのセクションに戻り
ましょう。
全体
が少し圧倒される可能性があります。
代わりに、
日本語の音を解きほぐすことから始めます。これは常に同じ
信念であり
、これを積極的に聞き
始めると、すぐにそれに気付くようになります。
先に述べたように、効果を再現する方法について常に第6の感覚をすばやく発達させます。最も上級の学習者
は、少なくともある程度はすでに声を出すことについて知っています
が
、私の経験では、ほとんど
の人が一言でそれを学ぶことに気づきました。
初めの言葉に基づいて、彼らは、デス
が数ヶ月後に
、ヒトではなく、
最終的に数年後に言い始めることを理解しています。
ねえ
、何年にもわたって浸透を聞いて
いる会話のほとんどすべての単語を適切に声に出して、彼らは
無意識のうちに
、たとえば、
これをしたくないと発音され
ていることに気付くようになります。
私たちの最初の年の教科書が私たち
がスイッチを入れてすぐに切り替えたい段階的なリスニング浸透を通してこのルールを拾いたくないと私たちに信じさせるのと同じように発音されていないことに気付く前に、1つの単語を40または50回言います
単語を1回だけ見たり、単語を聞いたりすることで、知り
たい能力にアクセスできます。単語が発声を経験するかどうかを知りたいだけ
です
。話し言葉の日本語で発声を積極的に聞き始め、発声
装置が回転し始め、次に
自分自身を見つけたときに
単語やフレーズ
に夢中になっているので、ここで話をしているのかどうか自問
してみてください。このレッスンはこれですべてです。
このエピソードで見たように、日本の音がお役に立てば幸いです。
常に同じ発音であるとは限りません。
今後のエピソード
では、この発音サブシリーズのエピソード2について
いくつかのアイデアを考えています
が、dvoicingは本当に
重要なルールと私は
かなりの数の質問があるかもしれないと感じて
いるので
、このビデオへの応答に応じて、
2週間待ってから
無関係なトピックに関する新しいビデオですので
、このアイデアについて皆さんがどう思うか教えてください。質問や懸念
がある場合は、今日はこれですべてです。
下にコメントを残してください。今後ともよろしくお願いいたします。お話しできること
を
楽しみにしております。 すぐにまた一緒にいる
ので、それがレッスンです。
みんながもう一度楽しんでくれることを願っています。誰かが興味を持っているなら
、それが正確なルールを覚えようとするのではなく、このレッスンの主なポイントだと思います。
高母音は、
無声
子音間または
無声子音と単語の終わりでの一時停止の間
で
食べて離婚します。ただ意識して食べて、ネイティブで離婚する例を聞いてみてください。
スピーチこれを
積極的に聞いていて、特に初心者の
場合は
、すぐに
気づき始めます。気づき始めると
、このビデオの最後で述べたように、自然に効果を再現し始めます。
まだパトレオン限定のビデオであるフォローアップレッスンを行うので、
誰かが私のパトレオンに行くことができることに興味があるなら
、私は近い将来、そのビデオに
いくつかの小さな変更を加えるつもりはない傾向があり
ます
このビデオでこの
uhスタイルで
やったことに対して、触れておきたいことがいくつかあり
ますが、このシリーズを宣伝するにはこれで十分だと思います。これ
を作成してくれたsufianにもう一度感謝します。
公開する可能性があり、将来
またこれができるようになることを願って
いますが、ここでビデオを終了します。今後ともよろしくお願いいたし
ます。またすぐに
皆さんとお話しし
ます。